hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to when
you're a kid all you can think about is
being in high school when you're in high
school all you can think about is being
in college when you're in college all
you can think about being an adult and
when you're an adult all you can think
about is being a kid again like fucking
sucks but for those few years of misled
optimism we have the Saturday morning
hit Saved by the Bell before Hannah
Montana Lizzie McGuire or any of those
other high school sitcom Saved by the
Bell was the first to fork out beautiful
teenagers with hideous clothes saying
horrible lies to an entire crowd of
canned laughter this is one of those
shows that captured the essence of the
80s oh well that sometimes seem like
we've traveled back in time to the
cherished decade to relive the fond and
wonder that the 1980s had to give us the
only problem it was made in my my gays I
mean look at this it's like a decade
behind were they just stuck in a time
warp or something but oh well this is
what we thought high school was gonna be
like when we were younger
before our dreams were shattered like
Elizabeth Berkeley's career what many of
you may not know is that Saved by the
Bell was not always called Saved by the
Bell
it was originally called good morning
miss bliss and the focus was not on the
students as much as their teacher miss
bliss played by Hayley Mills it ran for
about a year on the Disney Channel and
had some of the same cast as the
original show but I never caught on and
it was taken off the air after only one
season after that NBC picked up the show
and changed the title to Saved by the
Bell
and thus we were given the high school
character stereotypes that only
unimaginative writing could bring us for
example you got Zach you know the kid
always getting into trouble with his
Harebrained Schemes but always manages
to get out of trouble with his
irresistible smile that and a bucket
load of hair gel seriously I think
what's alive next you guys later
the good-looking Chuck there's very
similar to Zach in almost every way
except for um their names after that you
got Kelly the good-looking cheerleader
who has those insufferable on-again
off-again relationships with the main
characters I know this is high school
but how many times can you break up with
a person before they turn into a psycho
and start stalking you
nuts you got screech the nerdy little
geek a doofus dork ooh
judging by eight voice holds the record
for the longest time anyone has ever
gone through puberty well I thought I
was do you think he was kidnapped by
space creatures Kelly uh hi oh for God's
sakes well your testicles just drop
already after that you got Lisa the
fashionable self-centered mall brat who
is the object of Screech's affection you
were great in the hundred-yard - oh
thanks but I owe my victory to screech
you do oh yeah I pretended you were
chasing me out
finally you got Jessie the
self-righteous vegetarian politically
correct environmental animal rights
feminist in the group she was the most
popular character in the show I can't
believe my own boyfriend doesn't even
support me why do we need more oil
I mean auctioning off dates is just a
glorified meat market that's wrong
that's immoral that's dishonest well
excuse me for living now you might be
asking yourself haven't I seen her
before
except in something more degrading and
publicly humiliating yep this is the
exact same woman who started showgirls
one of the biggest cult films to ever
horrify audiences auctioning off dates
is sexist flesh peddling and should be
strictly forbidden
they go to a school principal by bolding
educational pushover mr. Belding what is
going on here that's a good one
oh gee miss Wentworth that's not fair
oh good news mr. Belding good news your
balls are right is that true
so what can you say about the show as a
whole well it's hard to sum up the
entire thing in general so let's take a
look at some individual episodes like
how about the episode with the fake IDs
this episode starts off at the kids
favorite hot spot the max look at this
place it's like the 80s interpretation
of the 50s
Zack helps out a girl with her flat tire
but it turns out she's over 18 and wants
to meet him at a club so screech comes
up with some fake IDs to get everybody
in can somebody tell me what's the point
of making a fake ID to show that you're
a teen when you're so obviously 24 you
know we never did discuss your feet well
I really don't oh yes I forgot to
mention this show has the most obnoxious
audience in the entire world I mean they
go nuts about everything
what if something happened that they
didn't know how to react to wrong last
night Jeff with bowling with his
roommates why just mind your own
business and stay out of my life or how
about the episode where Zach has to find
his family frequencies it turns out Zach
finishes a track meeting having not
worked up anything close to a sweat but
forgot he has to research his family
tree for a school project all he can
find though is a picture of a Native
American chief so like any high schooler
he bullshit's his way through the report
black Morris let's hear from you next
all right screech is going to assist me
ready screech really Kemosabe Oh God
after digging through old family papers
and pictures I learned that I'm part
American Indian I come from a long line
of fierce warriors and great hunters
maybe they roamed the wide open plains
in search of their daily food hungry and
the award for most Awkward racially
insensitive moment in Saturday morning
history goes to say butterball
now let's dig my dad's giving the
electric train when I was three okay so
obviously zach has to do the report
again but this time to help him out his
teacher sends him to a Native American
named chief Henry who knows a little
something about Zach's
tribe like Clint the white man and the
Indians get along why can't the Arabs
get along with his Raley's and what can
I get on my ex-wife did he just compare
the Battle of Arabs and Israelis to his
ex-wife okay Zach returns to give his
presentation dressing up as one of the
Village People and gives a much more
detailed speech he never did explain why
his people painted vaginas on their
chins but then again it is just a
three-minute speech wanting to tell his
mentor the good news
Zach suffers a heartbreaking blow a
friend advised passed away today chief
Henry died this morning
well of course how dramatically
convenient what do you think his Indian
name was dies with poetic plot points
fortunately he appears to zag in a dream
and tells him that it's okay to stop
grieving and move on
his life what I gotta go I'm being
fitted for wings wings you may like
angel wings so he's a Christian pagan
Native American huh go figure but most
people's favorite episodes are the ones
that have a message to convey like the
oil episode ah yes you all remember this
ground this is the one where oil is
found under a football field and a rich
Texan oil tycoon comes to join the kids
all somehow dream up the exact same
fantasy and imagine what would be like
to be the richest school in the county
my darling let's all go to the beach the
cameras already
meanwhile Zack comes across a duck named
Becky and forms a powerful friendship
with the innocent creature I wish I
didn't have to take you to the pond
tomorrow I can visit you all the time
when did this turn into an EB White's
kids book so let me be sure I got this
straight
one story involves Texas tycoons
drilling for oil and another story
involves a cute little ducky who lives
in the school pond oil plus ducky equals
I mean what could possibly go wrong
after all we all know that oil is the
safest and most non hazardous of all of
God's natural oh my god bad day but you
know she's not moving sach I know she's
probably a shot just please help us sir
yes yes but he must be in shock
surely shuffle through right right Zack
Becky's dead no no no no
can't make an omelet without breaking
snakes
you
worried about Becky Zack she's where the
oil can't hurt her now Oh faster than
you can say Texas teeth the gang bonds
together to put that evil oil tycoon
back at his place the Cal star in the
school board will be partners in
building a beautiful new Bayside it will
cost you nothing
yes but will it bring back Becky will it
bring back Becky that's not true
what do you mean young man yes you the
lone hero in the back where are the oak
trees behind the library
well I'm afraid we'll have to replace
them now you mean cut them down and put
up an oil derrick like this oh oh let's
go what happens if there's a bigger
accident and oil gets over everything
just like this oh and this is outrageous
oh this is most unorthodox I don't want
to go to school in an oil field we
already have a better Bayside we just
didn't know it until now u-dub killing
mother father that's why kids just
remember oil is evil I mean what the
hell do we need oil for anyway oh you
run our cars but there's tons of other
natural energy resources to run our cars
like solar which is practically
non-existent so there's high break which
is far too expensive for anyone to
afford but there's electric which is
still on the developing stages so for
the time being I guess we're stuck with
oil even nasty oil
it kills ducks another episode I'm sure
you all remember is the drug episode but
Jesse gets addicted to caffeine pills
because he wants to pass geometry and do
well in her new girl rock
wai-wai-wai-wait a girl rock club how
the hell did that come along well it
turns out Zack we really thought the
three girls had potential so switch
dresses up as a female Irish janitor and
records them singing in the girls locker
finally something realistic I remember
when I
stuff like a female Irish janitor
recorded things in the girls locker room
why don't you just forget I said that
next time bring Nene so the recording is
given to a record producer who of course
lost it and the three girls decide to
put together a music video for them oh
god help me this is bad when music
videos didn't know they were insulting
our intelligence and also when they were
you know popular say what you will about
this song that these special effects are
just incredible like watch this
unbelievable stunt oh my god how did I
do that there was one person there and
then suddenly there's another is this
that mystical voodoo they talked about
called a jump cut also get a load of
this Oh their faces are dissolving over
the picture witchcraft feeling the
pressure
Jessie continues to take her caffeine
pills and because mildly annoying oh yes
I forgot to mention the popular music
sting which is played just before every
commercial break the weird thing is that
the music is so bland that you never
know if it's positive or negative until
you hear the subject matter guys is
struck oil
died in an oil spill there's oil
everywhere this music so vague you can
put it to anything hey everybody
Kent let's talk just oh ah oh no Lisa is
pregnant with screeches baby Wow
Zack just saved a puppy right after his
mother died you see the big scene
everyone remembers is near the end when
she has her giant breakdown in front of
Zack I just mean why these pills you
mean you really are taking drugs I need
Wow
I mean wow I had no idea that caffeine
pills could turn you into such a
horrible actor well I'm getting rid of
these babies right now scoot
old-fashioned mescaline for me
oh god this dude
finally I want to talk about one more
episode this is my personal favorite
it's called rockumentary and it's this
strange kind of behind the music look at
the kids after they make it big as a
rock band you heard right they make it
big as a rock band just look at some of
the clothes they wear it's like the 80s
are trying to die but someone keeps
trying to resuscitate them just like a
decade die in peace look at this when
the hell did anyone wear bows on their
jeans are you a fucking birthday present
but I digress this odd little music
documentary is hosted by Casey Kasem of
all people as he apparently has mastered
the power of time travel to show you how
their story began apparently the group
practice in their garage playing their
instruments and lip-synching rather
horribly just look at Slater's drum work
he plays so well that the beats come out
before he even tapped
little did they know that fate was
running by their door yeah was there a
record producer named Brian fate who
haven't be drawn you past the garage
hello I'm Brian fight it's a little
funny
he of course turns them into rock
legends as they do concerts sign
autographs get awards from Bad
impersonators it's a dream come true now
one thing you might be asking yourself
is where's Jessie in all of this well
they saw how she did with the last rock
group she signed up with them gum yeah
they're not doing that again
so of course as their popularity built a
seductive PR woman steps in and seduces
Zack to leave the group and go solo
letting the fame go to his head Zack
agrees we alone oh and leads the group
to go do his own thing and she controls
everything about him even the way he
looks all right now I have to warn you
this next scene where Zack shows himself
in his brand-new look is is one of the
funniest things ever put on television
it will cause laughter
beyond your control just remember to
breathe inhale and exhale this has been
known to kill people people have
actually died from laughter I just want
you to keep that in mind before you
watch this take a deep breath all right
let's watch this
oh oh oh so um if you survive that zach
eventually gets back together with this
group and goes on to make music history
and then of course he wakes up because
it was all obviously a dream thank God
because if I look like MC Hammer and
princes white love child I would want to
be a dream too you know next year I'm
asking for weekdays off
so that's Saved by the Bell how does it
hold up it doesn't it's stupid silly and
loaded with idiotic cliches but I will
say that looking back on it it is pretty
harmless I mean I don't think it makes
kids any Dumber like some of the other
shows I've reviewed on here but if I was
to sum up this show in one word I would
say that it's dumb stupid crazy
dangerous stinks and then so I'm gonna
stop the Critic I remember so you don't
have to
you